oui oui on va demander rapidement aux
intervenants de nous rejoindre donc à
nier la henri bies pierre je sais pas
s'il est arrivé
marc philippe daubresse nous ont
rejoints yann de kerguéhennec l'ordre
des infirmiers voilà je crois que je
n'ai oublié personne
bonjour donc très rapidement parce qu'il
faut qu'on tienne absolument les délais
deux choses que je voudrais vous dire à
l'introduction sur la ruralité la
ruralité
vous le savez toutes et tous ces 80% de
notre territoire ces 21 millions
d'habitants et cette ruralité est en
grande difficulté en grande souffrance
avec un sentiment d'abandon extrêmement
fort malheureusement sentiment d'abandon
qui est confirmé par une réalité ces
territoires sont abandonnées il nous
faut absolument de les reconquérir
et c'est une des priorités des
républicains de mettre en place des
dispositifs extrêmement force pour la
ruralité à la fois des solutions
originales mais aussi des moyens
financiers tout à l'heure en intervenant
un peu un peu dévoilé ce qu'on va
annoncer tout à l'heure et que le
président nicolas sarkozy va nous y
voilà des moyens conséquents pour cette
ruralité et puis une deuxième remarque
que je voulais vous faire vous parlez
vous montrer la distorsion qu'il ya
entre le discours du président de la
république et du gouvernement et la
réalité sur le terrain
au mois de septembre dernier le
président de la république a mené sa
cour en province pour annoncer des
discours d'amour en direction de la
ruralité et trois semaines après au
parlement il a essayé de supprimer le
seul avantage fiscal qui existaient pour
les zones rurales à savoir une
exonération des cotisations sociales
pour les entreprises qui s'installent en
zone rurale et heureusement grâce un
certain nombre de députés nous avons pu
maintenir cet amendement donc voilà
montrez vous montrer combien on a un
discours du président de la république
du gouvernement et une réalité qui
malheureusement exactement inverse
voilà je cède la parole la parole pardon
à pierre morel avec qui nous partageons
cette fonction de secrétaire l'excellent
pierre morel avec qui nous partageons
cette cette fonction de secrétaire
national en charge de la ruralité voilà
pierre